one of the easiest ways that I increase
the productivity of a sales team is when
I read the sales script I look for the
parts where they talk about the features
they talk about the pieces of the
service of the product that they deliver
to the customer and usually it's dead
wrong and so we swap with the features
isn't benefits because that's what a lot
of people talk about but it's actually
anecdotal or stories that can relate the
experience to the customer rather than
having your laundry list of features I
like to give three analogies no more no
less that illustrate different aspects
of the product and what experiencing it
would look like and ideally stories of
people just like them experiencing the
result of the product the way they want
their problem to be solved